bonjour à tous suite cet après-midi du
projet de loi de finances pour 2011 et
de la mission outre mer
les sénateurs ont commencé l'examen de
cette mission ce matin et ils reprennent
cet après midi à l'article 77
je vous rappelle que les crédits de la
mission outre-mer sont en baisse le
ministère de l'outre-mer à cette année
un budget de un milliard 980 millions
d'euros
les sénateurs ultramarins sont donc
arrivés en force dans l'hémicycle et les
discussions se poursuivent tout de suite
pour le détail de ce budget direction
l'hémicycle très bonne séance la séance
et reprises
nous reprenons la discussion du projet
de loi de finances pour 2011 adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale dans la suite de
l'examen des crédits de la mission
outre-mer et articles 77 77 10 77 77 kw
à terre et 77 kw pièce nous sommes
parvenus à la réponse de madame
marie-luce penchard ministre chargée de
l'outre-mer vous avez la parole madame
la ministre
bonjour
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
la présentation du budget de la mission
outre-mer au titre du plf 2011 est pour
moi un moment particulier est un moment
de vérité car il me donne l'opportunité
de mettre en avant les grandes
orientations de l'action de l'état
outre-mer
je voudrais remercier le président de la
commission des lois jean jacques hyest
ainsi que son rapporteur christian
cointat pour leur accueil le 17 novembre
dernier à l'occasion d'une audition
devant cette commission
j'ai eu d'ailleurs aussi l'occasion
d'échanger avec plusieurs d'entre vous
sur les voies et moyens d'optimiser
l'action de l'état en outre-mer je pense
en particulier aux différents
rapporteurs eric doligé pour la
commission des finances claude leed pour
la commission des affaires économiques
et anne marie payet pour la commission
des affaires sociales je vais essayer de
répondre aux interrogations qui ont été
formulées sur les différents aspects du
budget de la mission outre-mer
si le budget de la mission outre-mer
s'inscrit dans l'effort national de
maîtrise de la dépense publique y
compris dans son volet relatif à la
dépense fiscale
cette contribution à l'effort national
est aujourd'hui juste et bien
proportionné et à ce titre je voudrais
remercier les sénateurs magra et
virapoullé pour leurs propos en
particulier lorsque le sénateur magra
aborder la question de la participation
d'outre-mer à l'effort national
oui je crois que les territoires
ultramarins dans le cadre de leur
appartenance à la république ne doivent
pas être un jour tenu responsable en
partie de la dette publique et je crois
que nous devons au contraire puisque
cette baisse n'est que provisoire être
fier d'avoir participé à cet effort
puisque c'était fort se fait dans des
proportions mesuré en effet le budget de
la mission s'établit à 2 milliards 156
millions d'euros en
risation d'engagement soit une légère
diminution de 0 55% et à 1 milliard neuf
en crédits de paiement soit une baisse
de 2,3 pour cent certains parlementaires
ultramarins en première analyse exprimé
des craintes sur cette légère baisse
annoncée je voudrais cet égard préciser
deux choses d'abord ce budget respecte
en 2011 les engagements pris pour
l'application de la lodeom et du ciom du
conseil interministériel de l'outre-mer
cette baisse n'est que provisoire
puisque dans le cadre du triennal 2011
2013 les autorisations d'engagement vont
de nouveau augmenter de 2% et les
crédits de paiement de 6 5% pour
s'établir dès 2012 à un niveau supérieur
au montant de la loi de finances 2010
j'ai aussi entendu certaines réserves
sur la mise en application de la lodeom
et des mesures du ciom et je voudrais y
répondre très vite
d'abord les 24 décrets d'application ont
été pris dans l'année qui a suivi
l'adoption de la loi ce qui est tout à
fait conforme aux délais habituels
observé l'entrée en vigueur de plusieurs
décret a eu des effets notables et
immédiat je pense en particulier à la
prime bagasse qui a donné un nouveau
souffle à la filière canne à sucre
notamment à la réunion où l'on estime à
10%
l'augmentation du revenu des planteurs
suite à la mise en oeuvre de cette
mesure
je pense à la création des zones
franches globales d'activité qui permet
il faut le dire aux entreprises
éligibles
un abattement de 80 % de l'impôt sur les
sociétés un abattement de 80 % des taxes
foncières sur les propriétés bâties et
non bâties et voire 100% sur la
contribution économique territoriale
ce n'est pas négligeable dans le
contexte actuel on parle beaucoup des
corrections apportées par la lodeom en
faisant croire à partir d'un chiffrage
des plus aléatoires que ce sont des
moyens en moins pour l'outre-mer alors
qu'en réalité il s'agissait de corriger
feydeau ben créé par les anciennes lois
de défiscalisation et là dessus monsieur
le sénateur serge larcher je crois que
le président a dit les choses
il l'avait annoncé avant son élection à
la présidence de la république qu'il
fallait corriger ses effets d'aubaine
mais aussi il faut parler des nouvelles
mesures supplémentaires décidée pour
l'outre-mer on les oublie trop je pense
aux fonds exceptionnel d'investissement
qui a permis de lancer des opérations
d'infrastructure pour un montant de 200
millions d'euros entre 2005 et 2010 je
pense au fonds de garantie en faveur du
secteur agricole et de la pêche 20
millions d'euros sur 2010-2012
je pense à la bonification des prêts
accordés par l'afd 30 millions d'euros
au profit du développement et de
l'innovation des petites et moyennes
entreprises et la dotation
exceptionnelle de mayotte en
construction scolaire puisque c'est un
million d'euros on va passer à 10
millions d'euros
et puis monsieur le sénateur patience je
crois qu'il faut aussi dire qu'il y à
une dotation pour la première fois de 10
millions d'euros pour la guyane
parce que le gouvernement a tenu compte
de la poussée démographique qu'on
observe dans ces territoires
alors l'ensemble de ces interventions de
l'état sont je crois indispensable dans
le contexte économique et sociale que
nous connaissons
voilà c'est un discours de vérité
nous l'avons toujours tenus nous
continuerons de le faire je crois que
même si ce n'est pas facile il faut
poursuivre dans cette démarche
ce courage politique est la marque de ce
gouvernement car je crois qu'il est
important d'établir des relations de
sincérité avec la population en
particulier avec les populations
d'outre-mer
parce que c'est un gage de conscience
pour construire l'avenir ensemble
je voudrais aussi vous confirmer que les
deux décrets sur la continuité
territoriale qui était prêt depuis le
mois d'avril 2010 mais dans la tente de
n'approuver communautaire vous le savez
enquêter pluie publié le 19 novembre
de même le décret sur l'aide au fret qui
était attendu par les opérateurs
économiques depuis plusieurs mois avait
été signé par moi-même et devait être
publié quelques jours n'est
malheureusement
heureusement le remaniement
gouvernemental nous a conduits à
relancer cette procédure du contreseing
et ceux de craie vous devrait être
publié dans les semaines à venir et je
voudrais dire aux sénateurs la foule ou
que s'agissant de la continuité
territoriale que bien évidemment ce
décret s'applique aussi à wallis et
futuna
il restera à prendre le décret de
création du gip du conflit d'intérêt
public pour la reconstruction des titres
de propriété j'ai souhaité par souci
d'efficacité que ce nouvel outil soit le
plus adapté possible et c'est pourquoi
j'ai demandé à andré valade ancien
fondateur et président du gip qui a 10
encore de réaliser une mission de
préfiguration postiers de la mise en
oeuvre les décisions qui ont été prises
lors du conseil interministériel de
l'outre-mer je vous confirme que les
trois quarts des 137 mesures sont
réalisées ou très avancée est d'ailleurs
un document élaboré par mon ministère a
été adressée à l'ensemble des
parlementaires cet été pour faire le
point sur l'état d'avancement des
décisions qui ont été prises au niveau
du scion le gouvernement a aussi fait
adopter le 3 novembre dernier une mesure
très importante par l'assemblée
nationale
un mâle amendement qui va permettre à
l'état de céder gratuitement ces
terrains non bâtis pour pouvoir
construire des logements sociaux
c'était une disposition très attendu des
bailleurs sociaux de tous les outre-mer
et sans attendre l'article l'examen de
cet article 77 10 je voudrais apporter
quelques précisions sur ce dispositif
qui a pu susciter des interrogations de
votre part il reprend ce dispositif une
logique d'un mécanisme de droit commun
inscrit dans le code général de la
propriété des personnes publiques et qui
permet une décote partielle de la valeur
vénale des terrains de l'état
lorsqu'ils sont cédés pour réaliser des
opérations d'intérêt général comme la
construction de logements sociaux
le gouvernement souhaitait aller plus
loin dans un double objectif d'abord
libérer du foncier pour le logement
social mais aussi agir sur les coûts de
production
c'est pourquoi il a choisi une cession
gratuite qui permet de répercuter
intégralement cette dernière sur le coût
des opérations de logement social au
surplus le gouvernement souhaite
faciliter la cession des terrains chaque
fois qu'elle correspond un projet social
les garanties ont d'ailleurs été
renforcée par l'assemblée nationale en
définissant un manteau minimum de
logements sociaux dans le programme de
construction
ce seuil de 30% proposé par l'assemblée
nationale est d'autant plus pertinent
puisqu'il existe déjà c'est celui prévu
dans l'article 199 undecies c du code
général des impôts qui régit la
défiscalisation du logement social
vous vous êtes également interrogé sur
les bénéficiaires potentiels de ce
mécanisme le champ des bénéficiaires
n'est effectivement pas circonscrit par
l'article 77 bis mais il l'est par la
destination du foncier appelés à être
cédés
enfin l'acquéreur s'engage dans un délai
très contre un employé le foncier pour y
réaliser des logements sociaux
éventuellement des équipements
collectifs de la sorte ce sont les
collectivités les établissements publics
fonciers et les bailleurs sociaux qui
sont les bénéficiaires des dispositifs
qu'il s'agisse de la lodeom ou du ciom
le projet de loi de finances pour 2011
traduisent sans ambiguïté tous les
engagements concernant ces deux
dispositifs majeur sur le plan
budgétaire
il n'y a donc pas de raison objectifs à
tenir un discours anxiogène ce n'est pas
bon pour l'économie ultramarine
ce n'est pas bon pour l'image de nos
territoires cela porte atteinte à la
crédibilité de la parole de l'outre-mer
et enfin nous risquons avec le temps de
faire le lit de tous ceux qui veulent
démontrer que de toute manière
il n'y a pas de solution avec le système
actuel et que seule la voie qu'il
propose est la bonne
c'est pourquoi si je peux comprendre les
divergences analyse en fonction des
sensibilités politiques
je crois qu'on doit essayer de tenir un
discours mesuré sans passion et
responsable est la raison doit toujours
l'emporter sur leur s si nous voulons
rétablir la confiance indispensable à la
reprise des activités économiques et il
me semble que tous ceux qui ont de
l'intérêt pour l'outre-mer auront à
coeur de partager cette réflexion avec
moi mesdames et messieurs les députés
les sénateurs pardon
malgré la légère baisse des crédits je
le redis le budget de l'outre-mer
conservera en 2011 ses capacités
d'intervention en particulier sur les
deux priorités que sont le logement et
l'emploi
d'abord sur le logement
l'engagement du gouvernement en
particulier pour le logement social a
toujours été une priorité depuis 2007
lors du conseil interministériel de
l'outre-mer vous l'avez rappelé le
gouvernement a décidé d'intégrer dans la
ligne budgétaire unique
les crédits exceptionnels du plan de
relance et de maintenir ce niveau de lb
eu dans le cadre de la programmation
triennale des lois de finances cet
engagement il est tenu comme vous pouvez
le constater à la lecture des documents
budgétaires malgré un contexte
budgétaire difficile les autorisations
d'engagement de la ligne budgétaire
unique sont sanctuarisés de 2011 à 2013
à hauteur de 274 5 millions d'euros
la ville demeure et demeurera sans
contexte le socle du financement du
logement social outre-mer alors certains
ont pu s'interroger sur l'évolution des
crédits de paiement 2010 et 2011
je le répète le montant est lié au
budget correspond au rythme d'exécution
des opérations dans en cours et non pas
au rythme d'engagement des opérations il
est d'ailleurs totalement en phase avec
l'exécution budgétaire de là
2009 au terme de laquelle je rappelle
aucune date n'a été constituée auprès
des bénéficiaires des subventions de la
hume budgétaire unique s'agissant de la
défiscalisation du logement social
je vais un tout petit peu plus
m'attarder parce que je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup d'interrogations sur ce sujet
vous le savez c'est un dispositif récent
à ce jour 64 dossiers ont été déposés à
léa vraiment au niveau central en 2009
et 2010 64 dossiers qui représente près
de cinq mille cinq cents logements
sociaux 20 ont fait l'objet d'un accord
de principe soit 1629 l'objet je mens
bien évidemment je ne me satisfais pas
de ce résultat car je sais que les
besoins sont importants et que 4000
logements sont en attente d'un agrément
qui doit être donné le plus rapidement
possible pour permettre de répondre aux
besoins considérables dans ce domaine
alors je voudrais vous rassurer
lors de la réunion que j'ai récemment
présidé sur ce thème
nous avons convenu avec les
représentants des bailleurs sociaux de
critères de traitement en priorité au
premier rang de ces critères pour les
départements d'outre-mer mayotte et
saint martin figure les opérations déjà
financé au titre de la ligne budgétaire
unique
au passage vous observerez que ce
critère de priorité que j'ai proposé
donc démontre pleinement qu'une
opération peut cumuler lb et
défiscalisation
je le dis avec beaucoup de solennité
parce que c'est des propos qui ont été
tenus ici autour de la lodeom
le cumul entre aides budgétaires et
défiscalisation n'en n'ai aucun cas
interdit ce serait contraire à la loi
mais le cumul n'est pas non plus
systématique
ce serait aussi contraire à la loi et à
l'esprit de la loi
des interprétations erronées de
l'instruction du 1er juin 2010 sur les
opérations de construction de logement
social ont pu être faits ici ou là je le
reconnais j'ai pris l'engagement
parce que ça ne correspondait nullement
à ma philosophie auprès des bailleurs
sociaux de compléter cette instruction
pour lever toute ambiguïté
au niveau des services de l'état et
rappelait également qu'en termes de
procédure c'est la décision
d'attribution de la sbu qui doit
intervenir en premier mais je
continuerai également à veiller à ce que
la défiscalisation notamment lorsqu'il
ya cumul avec la ligne budgétaire unique
ne favorise pas l'inflation des coûts de
production
je le rappelle la philosophie de la
défiscalisation du logement social
l'esprit de la lodeom
c'était d'augmenter la production de
logements sociaux pour répondre aux
besoins nos compatriotes ultramarins
ce n'est pas nourrir une inflation des
coûts et nous avons tous le devoir
d'être vigilant sur ce point et c'est
pour cette raison qu'il est nécessaire
de poser les conditions pratiques du
cumul des financements je sais que ce
sont notamment les opérations en vefa
monté de manière exceptionnelle pour
faire face à la crise qui ont des coûts
plus élevés mais cela ne peut être que
conjoncturelles le cumul des aides doit
donc être réservée aux opérations qui
justifie des surcoûts objectifs par
exemple des fondations spéciales ou un
surcoût foncier ou qui sont conçus pour
proposer des loyers inférieurs aux
loyers plafonds
j'ai entendu aussi les critiques sur la
complexité des procédures de
défiscalisation et j'y ai consacré une
longue réunion de travail avec les
représentants des bailleurs sociaux
d'outre-mer le 12 novembre dernier de
manière très approfondie très
pragmatique nous avons collectivement
porter un diagnostic sur les pointes
blocage j'ai formulé des propositions et
je peux vous indiquer les orientations
qui ont été décidées par le gouvernement
pour ce qui concerne les services
j'ai donné des instructions qu'il donne
un avis dans le mois qui suivent la
réception du dossier
faute de quoi la vie sera considéré
comme favori afin de clarifier les
règles du jeu mais services vont
compléter l'instruction du 1er juin 2010
et avec mon collègue en charge du budget
nous avons décidé d'établir un dossier
type pour les demandes de
défiscalisation ces dossiers ce dossier
devra bien évidemment être le plus
proche de celui exigé pour les demandes
de subvention au titre de la nba
j'ajoute aussi que nous allons également
relevé le seuil de déconcentration des
décisions fixé actuellement à 10
millions d'euros ce qui répond me
semble-t-il à la demande d'anne marie
payet au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales l'expérience en effet
à démontrer que les procédures au plan
local s'articule beaucoup plus
facilement entre elle et le délai moyen
d'instruction il est deux fois plus
court que pour l'agrément national
toutes ces mesures et en particulier les
agréments pour les dossiers prioritaires
dont la liste a été communiquée par les
bailleurs sociaux sur la base des
critères que nous avons défini ensemble
seront prises je m'engage avant la fin
de cette année vous le voyez depuis plus
de trois ans la détermination du
gouvernement pour le logement outre-mer
demeure intacte et le budget que vous
examiner aujourd'hui en témoigne
et je reviens de la réunion à titre
d'exemple je peux vous faire le point de
la situation aujourd'hui par rapport à
l'année dernière nous avions engagé nous
avions engagé au niveau des
autorisations d'engagement 2300
logements
nous avons financé par lampard dont 2300
logements cette année nous allons
financer 3600 logements pour la réunion
et nous allons mettre en chantier au
titre de l'année 2010 à la réunion 4300
le chemin je réfléchis d'ailleurs à
élaborer un tableau de bord de suivi
pour permettre à chaque territoire de
voir l'évolution à la fois sur les
opérations qui sont financés par l'état
sur les opérations qui font l'objet d'un
engagement sur les opérations qui font
l'objet d'un commencement de chantier et
sur les opérations qui sont réalisés
pour que toute la transparence et qu'il
n'y ait plus d'ambiguïté sur ces
chiffres
l'autre priorité de ce budget cela ne
vous surprendra pas concerne l'emploi et
la formation
l'augmentation des crédits sur le
programme en poids outre-mer trouve en
effet sa principale explication vous
avez pu le remarquer dans
l'accroissement capacitaire du service
militaire adapté sma
le doublement à terme du nombre de
stagiaires permettra d'accueillir dès
2011 mille volontaires
de plus conformément aux engagements du
président de la république de février
2009 les crédits supplémentaires alloués
aux essais main serviront d'une part à
réhabiliter les infrastructures aussi à
construire des bâtiments mais a amélioré
bien évidemment l'encadrement dont
bénéficient ces jeunes je serai
vigilante pour que le haut niveau
d'insertion parce que je sais que vous y
êtes particulièrement attachés et
d'excellence de la formation dispensée
par le sm a soit maintenue notamment
grâce à des partenariats avec les
acteurs de la formation professionnelle
de la remise à niveau scolaire ainsi
qu'avec les fédérations professionnelles
implantées dans les territoires en
matière de formation professionnelle je
voudrais aussi que nous ils ont tous
bien à l'esprit le rôle important que
joue la donne c'est par exemple le cas
pour la mise en oeuvre de la politique
de formation qualifiante en mobilité au
profit des jeunes ultramarins
le passeport mobilité formation
professionnelle prévoit ainsi une
formation pouvant aller jusqu'à 24 mois
hors du territoire d'origine dès lors
que la formation n'est pas dispensé sur
place et en octobre 2010 lagence a déjà
pris en charge plus de 5000 jeunes ce
chiffre est éloquent
il est d'autant plus que la qualité est
au rendez vous puisque ce sont en
moyenne cinq jeunes sur 10 qui
obtiennent un diplôme en fin de parcours
et ce qui est encore plus remarquable
dans le contexte ultra marin sait que
près d'un jeune sur deux qui a validé sa
formation trouvent un emploi dans
l'année qui suit
47 % exactement selon les chiffres de la
dent mais je demande à la donne pour
2011 de molise mobilisé toutes ses
marges de manoeuvre pour encore faire
mieux et je voudrais aussi évoqué ces
jeunes actifs ultra marins qui ont des
difficultés à trouver un emploi durable
je le sais et qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier du revenu de solidarité
active
vous le savez la loi généralisant le rsa
a été votée dans un grand consensus
mais pour l'outre-mer nous avons décidé
en lien avec les collectivités et en
raison de la crise de février 2009
de mettre en place un dispositif adapté
qui est le revenu supplémentaire
temporaire d'activité le est resté à mai
par rapport aux airs et stages je peux
vous assurer que nous serons prêts au
1er janvier à ouvrir ce nouveau
dispositif cette nouvelle allocation et
à gérer la transition des bénéficiaires
qui en font la demande du rsp à vers le
rsa et la dotation m'insulter nature
gillot sera calculée selon les mêmes
critères que ceux définis pour les
départements métropolitains
s'agissant de la continuité territoriale
dans l'attentes d'egypte
je voudrais préciser que les moyens de
l'agencé de l'outre-mer pour la mobilité
ladom ont été renforcées pour gérer le
dispositif ainsi l' agence a été
autorisé à recruter 30 équivalents temps
plein supplémentaires pour assurer les
fonctions de guichet d'instruction et de
contrôler les moyens humains et
financiers seront bel et bien là en 2011
j'ai pu le vérifier moi-même les 20 19
et 20 novembre dernier à l'occasion de
l'inauguration de deux nouvelles
antennes de ladom respectivement à la
martinique et à la guadeloupe
et hier en visitant lagence de la
réunion je voudrais aussi vous indiquer
que 45,3 100 millions d'euros sont
prévus pour ce dispositif chaque année
pendant trois ans ou oui il ya bien de
nous des critères nouveaux d'allocation
de cette aide qui ont été fixées par la
lodeom
oui ce sont bien nos compatriotes dont
les ressources sont les plus faibles qui
sont ciblés en priorité
je persiste à dire que la mise en oeuvre
de la continuité dans l'ensemble des
départements et territoires de
l'outre-mer doit être plus équitable
même si j'ai prévu de faire une
évaluation de son fonctionnement à l'été
2011 et je proposerai si nécessaire des
mesures de correction en particulier
pour les territoires du pacifique
je souhaiterais également vous dire
quelques mots sur un dispositif qui joue
un rôle clé en faveur de la création
d'emplois dans les entreprises
ultramarines par le renforcement de leur
compétitivité
il s'agit des crédits du programme 138
consacré à la compensation des
exonérations de charges sociales
la réduction du coût de travail ou trois
mains est inscrite dans une politique
désormais ancien de compensation des
handicaps structurels
j'ai eu l'occasion l'année dernière de
vous indiquer que la loi pour le
développement économique des outre-mer
de la lodeom à améliorer l'efficacité du
dispositif en le recentrant par un
mécanisme de dégressivité renforcée sur
les bas salaires sur les petites
entreprises de moins de onze salariés et
sous les entreprises des secteurs
d'activité jugées priorité sachez que
pour 2011 le montant inscrit en loi de
finances
permettra de couvrir les besoins estimés
par les organismes de sécurité sociale
sans et j'insiste sur ce point
créer de nouveau un pays ce montant de 1
me un milliard a été retenu au lieu de 1
milliard sur 50 millions demandés par
les organismes de sécurité sociale je le
sais mais je voudrais répondre sur ce
point notamment aux rapporteurs et leur
dire qu'il n'ya pas de sous-estimation
de la part du gouvernement les
organismes de sécurité sociale n'ont en
effet pas souhaité intégrer dans leurs
prévisions l'impact parce qu'il ya une
réforme des exonérations de charges
sociales est estimé à 63 millions sur
l'année 2011 ce sont toutes les
conséquences de la lodeom qu'il faut
pouvoir tirer à l'occasion du budget
2011 et cela explique nos divergences
d'analysé
mesdames et messieurs vous avez souhaité
également interrogé à plusieurs reprises
sur la politique de santé outre mer
c'est un sujet qui était d'ailleurs dans
le cas de votre mission d'information
pour conduire la politique de santé
outre mer
nous avons en complément des dispositifs
national de guide le conseil
interministériel de l'outre-mer du 6
novembre 2009 et sur un plan plus centré
sur l'offre de soins le plan santé
outre-mer
concernant le plan santé outre-mer de
nombreuses actions ont déjà été engagés
je pense par exemple aux mesures
concernant les créances irrécouvrables
ou encore la révision engagé dès
coefficient géographique qui permettent
de prendre en considération les surcoûts
spécifique aux départements d'outre-mer
je pense également au plan hôpital 2012
dont un volet significatif concerne les
départements
d'outre-mer notamment sous laon de la
mise aux normes parasismiques je
rencontrerai prochainement mes collègues
xavier bertrand et nora berra à ce sujet
s'agissant des mesures du ciom
je reviendrai pas sur le développement
des filières hospitalo universitaires
dans l'océan indien et dans les
départements français d'amérique mais je
voudrais insister
en cette journée mondiale de lutte
contre le sida sur le plan riche vih et
sida infections sexuellement
transmissibles pour la période 2010 2014
ce plan comporte en son sein un plan
complémentaire est adapté pour les
populations outre-mer il reprend ainsi
l'orientation fort du ciom adapter nos
outils nationaux contexte d'outre-mer et
c'est pourquoi y'a les campagnes de
prévention et d'information qui seront
désormais adapté de même le plan
comporte des mesures ambitieuses pour
que le dépistage du vih soit plus
systématique proposer systématiquement
proposer aux populations d'outre-mer
c'est une demande forte je pense en
particulier en guyane et qu'il se fasse
plus tôt c'est à dire avant que la
maladie ne soit déclaré l'autorisation
récemment donné de réaliser des tests de
dépistage rapide va également dans ce
sens en conclusion sur ces chapitres
voudra dire que le ministère de
l'outre-mer mais s'il n'est pas pilote
dans ce domaine puisque sa relève
bien évidemment du ministre de la santé
soutient aussi des initiatives le plus
souvent associative dans le domaine de
la santé et nous apportons ainsi en
concours financier significatif autres
et par action de même que nous soutenons
des associations de prévention en
matière de vih sida
autre volet qui me paraît important dé
développer devant vous c'est le
développement économique et social et
outre-mer qui dépend bien évidemment de
l'action des collectivités territoriales
dont les investissements je le rappelle
représente 2 tient et trois quarts de la
commande publique locale ce sont les
collectivités territoriales qui sont le
plus souvent maîtres d'ouvragé des
opérations de construction et dans cette
période de crise économique mondiale que
nous avons connus fin 2008 et en 2009 à
grave et malheureusement par la crise
sociale de 2009
pour les antilles guyane et la réunion
il est important il est en a bien
conscience de pouvoir relancer par la
commande publique l'économie
c'est pourquoi l'état continuera en 2011
à apporter son soutien à travers sa
politique contractuelle
à ce titre on parle beaucoup des crédits
de paiement mais moi je voudrais vous
soulignez quand même que le volume des
crédits prévus pour le financement des
contrats de projets de développement des
territoires sont en augmentation aussi
de 15 millions par rapport à 2010 je
rappelle à cet hommage à cette occasion
l'engagement qui a été pris par le
premier ministre de maintenir au niveau
du contrat actuel en nouvelle calédonie
l'engagement financier de l'état hors
opérateurs c'est à dire plus de 370
millions d'euros pour le futur contrat
de développement 2011 2015
enfin l'effort financier de l'état en
matière de politique contractuelle
permettra aussi de garantir une
enveloppe pour le futur contrat de
saint-martin 2011 2013 et pour le
renouvellement de celui de wallis et
futuna
sans compter monsieur le sénateur dénis
d'être chez very l'effort toujours
constant de l'état pour
saint-pierre-et-miquelon et à ce sujet
je voudrais vous indiquer que la mise en
terre plate et un thé en sa pierre et
miquelon les dispositifs d aide aux
familles pour permettre effectivement de
couvrir le coût des adaptateurs est
applicable aussi à saint pierre et
miquelon et s'agissant du projet de
décryptage je suis en lien avec le
ministère de la culture pour rechercher
une solution la moins pertinents la
moins pénalisante pardon pour les
habitants de saint pierre et miquelon
quelques mots si vous m'y a autorisé sur
le fonds exceptionnel d'investissement
j'ai bien noté que le montant
d'autorisations d'engagement prévue en
2011 est source de perplexité pour
certains d'entre vous je voudrais vous
dire la chose suivante
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il est de bonne
politique de faire d'abord face à des
échéances à certaines échéances il avant
de contracter de nouvelles opérations il
faut d'abord réaliser celles qui ont été
financés notamment au titre du fonds
exceptionnel d'investissement puisque
celui ci a été doté de 10 millions
d'euros d'autorisations de programme
chat mais sur les années antérieures
c'est plus de 200 millions d'euros
d'autorisations d'engagement qui ont été
mobilisés et à cette date les opérations
sont engagés certes mais elles sont loin
d'être réalisés comme la ministre de
façon plus spécifique je voudrais
mentionner les mesures relatives à
certains territoires en particulier ceux
qui répondent à des besoins
d'accompagnement je pense notamment à la
dgd eux nous aurons l'occasion d'en
parler lors de l'examen de certains les
amendements pour conclure ce que je
voudrais vous dire que si les crédits de
la mission outre-mer représente que 15 %
de l'effort budgétaire en faveur de
l'outre-mer
mon ministère n'a pas vocation à devenir
le gestionnaire unique des crédits en
faveur de l'outre-mer
mais pour autant je voudrais dire devant
cette assemblée que nous devons prendre
garde à l'idée selon laquelle nous
pourrions traiter les questions de
l'outre-mer sans le ministère chargé de
l'outre-mer
parce que avec les évolutions
institutionnelles demain nous aurons
besoin d'apporter des réponses
spécifiques territoire par territoire
que ce le ministre chargée de
l'outre-mer pour apporter ou initiés
dans la mise en place des politiques
nationales
aujourd'hui c'est mon rôle d'y veiller
d'y veiller et demain je pense que sera
lé sur ce rôle sera encore beaucoup plus
renforcée avec le changement des statuts
prévue prochainement notamment au niveau
de la martinique et de la guyane
je vous remercie de votre attention si
madame 1 min
nous allons procéder oui monsieur le
président arthuis
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues je souhaite faire le
point sur le déroulement de notre
discussion budgétaire
je vous prends à témoin que nous
dérapons par rapport au programme
même les ministres peuvent aller au delà
du temps imparti
c'est ainsi que nous avons déjà reporté
la discussion de l'article 99 de la
mission ville et logement
cet article 99 viendra en discussion
samedi après midi de même que les
crédits de la mission politique des
territoires est d'ores et déjà compte
tenu des 26 amendements qui restent en
discussion sur les crédits de la mission
outre-mer
je suis obligé de considérer que la
discussion des crédits de la mission
santé de la mission engagement financier
de l'état qu'on spéciale participations
financières de l'état et de la mission
provisions qui était programmé ce soir
et bien pour ces trois missions les
crédits viendront en discussion samedi
en fin d'après-midi et sans doute samedi
soir les prochains décalage seront des
portes
reporter sans doute dimanche matin
étant entendu que nous avons également
un menu particulièrement copieux
d'articles non rattachés de la seconde
partie qui nous oblige à programmer
l'ouverture de la séance
dimanche après midi et dimanche soir
donc je me permet de lancer un appel à
la concision dans la présentation des
amendements dans la discussion des
amendements et si possible dans
l'explication de vote
je vous remercie de votre compréhension
et je vous demande pardon pour ces
précisions
mais c'est pour permettre à ceux de nos
collègues qui avaient prévu
de siéger en fin de journée sur
l'émission que je vient de déclarer
reporter quand j'ai cru devoir faire
cette déclaration il ya monsieur le
président at vous est donnée de cette
modification de l'ordre du jour qui sera
reprise par la conférence des présidents
et nous allons procéder à l'examen des
amendements portant sur les crédits de
la mission outre-mer figurant à l'étape
des l'amendement 250 présentée par
monsieur gillot madame la présidente mes
chers collègues cet amendement a pour
objet de les réinjecter autres maires
les économies réalisées grâce à nouvelle
réforme de la défiscalisation des
investissements productifs outre-mer et
à la suppression de la défiscalisation
des investissements photovoltaïque
outre-mer économies fiscales évaluées à
230 millions d'euros
en effet ces décisions ont un impact
direct sur les investissements outre-mer
aussi il est proposé d'affronter du même
montant
330 millions d'euros les actions 1 2 et
8 du programme 123 de la mission entre
maires afin que ces crédits puissent
permettre d'abonder la levée eu des
contrats de plan état région et autres
contrats de logements et le fond ou
d'accession à l'investissement pour que
l'investissement outre-rhin ne sera pas
ralenti encore davantage merci madame la
présidente son âme la mini semi chaque
collègue
cet amendement vise donc à transférer
305 millions d'euros du programme emploi
outre mer vers le programme conditions
du outre-mer il est censé traduire la
réinjection aux crédits budgétaires des
économies réalisées sur les dispositifs
de défiscalisation notamment sur le
photovoltaïque
j'indique déjà de manière générale que
la commission des finances n'a pu se
réunir pour examiner l'ensemble des
amendements extérieur toutefois l'avis
de la commission des finances serait que
cette réinjection ne peut recueillir un
avis favorable de notre part en effet la
réduction des niches fiscales ne vise
pas à réinjecter les économies réalisées
en crédits budgétaires
mais à réduire le déficit de l'état qui
je vous le rappelle atteindre à 92
milliards d'euros en 2011
la vie et donc défavorable à vis du
gouvernement
même le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs par rapport à cet amendement
le gouvernement émet un avis défavorable
parce que cet amendement va accroître la
dette à l'égard des organismes sociaux
dans ces conditions il n'est pas
acceptable
explications de vote
il n'y a pas de demande je mets aux voix
à l'amendement 250 qui est pour et qui
est contre il n'est pas adopté le 2 151
amendement 251 messieurs patients cet
amendement a pour objet d'abonder
l'action un logement du programme 123
conditions de vie outre-mer de 57
millions d'euros notamment au profit de
la sbu et des autres dépenses à
caractère social de ce programme
en effet le gouvernement à réaliser une
économie de 5 57 millions d'euros en ne
craignant pas le rsa en outre-mer dès
2009 comme en métropole selon le rapport
le rapport du député victoria
il s'agit donc de s'assurer que cette
économies réalisées sur les dépenses
sociales outre-mer soient réinjectées
dans le même secteur
en compensation le même montant en
autorisations d'engagement
si l'entrée des paiements est supprimée
sur l'action d'un du programme 138
il reviendra au ministère de l'outre-mer
et à celui d'économie des finances de
prouver les crédits correspondants afin
de compenser aux organismes de sécurité
sociale les exonérations de charges
envie de la commission le rapporteur
oui madame la présidente madame le
ministère collègues d'écouté
l'explication est exactement la même que
celle qui a été donné par mon collègue
mathieu il ya quelques instants
donc effectivement la commission des
favorables et défavorables en ce qui
concerne ce transfert qui est demandé
entre emplois outre mer et conditions de
vie outre-mer à vis du gouvernement
madame la présidente
avis défavorable pour les mêmes motifs
évoqués par rapport à l'amendement qui
vient d'être examinée tout à l'heure
l'explication de vote
il n'y en a pas je mets aux voix le 251
kg est pour et qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté le 2 153 monsieur larcher
je suis madame à beni hssen chers
collègues logement social est depuis
longtemps considérée comme une des
priorités du budget de notre comme et
les besoins dans ce domaine sont énormes
et qu'il ne cesse d'augmenter alors que
l'offre de logement ne cesse de baisser
ainsi pour l'ensemble des départements
d'outre-mer seul 2600 logements sociaux
neufs ont été financés en 2009 pour un
besoin de 45000 à un martin qui faute
d'être 2000 logements sociaux par un
seul 624 ont été programmés à 2010 et
134 son livre seul 664 était programmée
en 2010 et sans contact
ils sont ouvriers pour répondre à cette
situation catastrophique le gouvernement
a mis en place en 2009 un dispositif de
défiscalisation unique pour le joint en
outre-mer de vont relayer les crédits de
la nba cette ligne bleue cette ligne de
logements inscrits sur la mission
première de vont par ailleurs être sont
quasi je tiens à préciser qui semblait
que pour moi pour vous madame la
ministre que tu as lease et veut dire
aux lieux maintenir à l'identique alors
que pour moi je crois que pour la
plupart et pour la plupart des élites
rohmer cela veut dire maintenir un
financement important par le biais de
subventions
force est de constater vous lui que la
mise en oeuvre la défiscalisation en
logement social ne fonctionne pas et que
l'abus perd 20 avec un mur d'eau qui
plus est résidente et puis le racing
préfets des départements autres mais à
qui indiquent précisément que sauf cas
particuliers le recours à l'exclusion va
produire à une modération de la
situation voire à une absence totale de
subventions madame agnès person des
trucs dupe on perçoit nettement à
travers notamment ses instructions une
volonté de réduire à terme le
financement de la nba mais le logement
social ne doit pas des pôles aussi en
majorité des investissements privés car
seul
véritable augmentation elle doit
permettre à terme pour les départements
d'outre-mer de combler des besoins qui a
vu le jour ainsi cet abonnement
propose-t-il dabondy le mouvement tu as
pris le 20 à 25 millions d'euros sur les
crédits destinés à l'aide au fret
puisque depuis 2009 2010 c'est peut-être
d'été prévus au budget mais n'a jamais
été utilisée
voilà merci et à vis de la commission
merci madame la présidente bichat
collègues et il s'agit donc de
transférer 25 millions du programme hamp
outre-mer vers le programme conditions
de l'outre-mer est augmentée de 25
millions d'euros la ligne et le but
alors chers collègues sénateurs
l'intention est tout à fait louable mais
la commission rappelle que depuis
plusieurs années selon elle les crédits
du programme ans pour votre mère sont
sous budgétisé et d'ailleurs les
commission propose un amendement pour
l'image aurait on va le voir tout de
suite là par conséquent réduire le
montant des crédits de ce programme ne
nous paraît pas opportun et l'avis est
défavorable à vis du gouvernement
merci madame la présidente je voudrais
avant de faire connaître la position du
gouvernement en dire deux choses d'abord
les crédits de la ligne budgétaire
unique sont bien sanctuary zay
puisqu'ils sont prévus sur trois ans
pour le même montant
deuxièmement votre amendement va
conduire à la non application du décret
concernant l'aide au fret en ce décret
vient d'être signé et il est très
attendu par les milieux économiques donc
j'émets un avis défavorable par rapport
à votre proposition monsieur le sénateur
oui monsieur larcher
merci madame la présidente madame la
mise
je rencontre puisque vous me dites que
l'arrêté sera signée il ya aucune raison
dans ses collections effectivement que
je me retire
mais nous avons notre parole qui est
certaine la parole de l'état y dort de
spa et par conséquent aussi lourd
je retire mon avènement ainsi que le
suivant
250 cas donc le 254 également et retiré
l'amendement numéro 10 de la commission
messier de luge et madame la présidente
l'amendement numéro 10 propose un
transfert des conditions de vie
outre-mer de 24 1823 24 millions huit
cent vingt trois mille euros vers
emplois outre mer vous savez qu'il y a
des difficultés actuellement au niveau
des organismes de sécurité sociale qui
constate des pertes importantes donc
l'objectif est de réduire cette partie
de pêche qui est estimé actuellement à
62,9 millions d'euros ça c'est le
premier motif d'autre part l'objectif
est de supprimer pour un même montant
donc les crédits de l'action sanitaire
social culture jeunesse et sports du
programme conditions de vie outre mer
relatives au financement de l' agence de
santé des îles wallis et futuna rne
entendu ce matin notre collègue à ce
sujet donc ça nous intérêt très
dans tant de madame le ministre sur le
sujet sachant que la commission des
finances a proposé cette modification
est ce transfert merci à vis du
gouvernement roumain présidente mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
ces crédits concernant notamment les
agences de santé wallis et futuna sont
tout à fait justifiés sur le sur le
budget du ministère de l'outre-mer
puisque c'est une chance qui ne riez pas
comparable aux agences régionales de
santé
aujourd'hui ces démissions qui sont
dévolues aux hôpitaux formation encore
aux professionnels de santé c'est un
outil indispensable pour alice et futuna
et de plus le transfert de crédit ne va
pas au bénéfice des crédits de la
mission santé donc ce serait une charge
pour l'état ou à considérer que l'agent
ce serait plus opérationnelle ce qui
n'est pas concevable regarde sa mission
au niveau de wallis et futuna donc dans
ces conditions
j'émets un avis défavorable où je
souhaiterais que le reporter puis se
retirer cet amendement
oui ce
à porter merci mon avis la présidence
que nous avons voulu le faire avec cet
amendement s'est attiré l'attention du
be sur ce qu'il nous semble être un
dysfonctionnement du ministère et malgré
vos propos mais dans le ministère tous
les cas moi je continue à penser que la
santé à wallis et futuna ne relève pas
du ministère de l'outre-mer mais relève
du ministère de la santé
alors certes on va pas décidé le 15
décembre de supprimer les crédits pour
l'équipement spécialisé de wallis futuna
mais on voulait seulement attirer votre
attention mais attirer votre attention
en souhaitant que vous nous disiez s'il
y avait des pistes de réflexion dans les
années à venir mais bien entendu nous
retirons l'amendement 249 monsieur
gillot cet amendement a pour objet
d'éviter la disparition programmée de
l'institut de formation carrière à nice
ratisse intérêt social efficace de
dieppe l'efficace intervient sur le
champ de l'insertion par la formation et
la validation des acquis de l'expérience
au profit d'un public issus
essentiellement des dom et des comme
depuis plus de 30 ans l'ifca sa compagne
des milliers de jeunes issus des dom com
vers l'emploi dans les carrières à nice
400r et social il participe ainsi à
donner du sens aux notions de solidarité
de coaching et territorial avec un taux
d'insertion se situant au taux de 80%
aujourd'hui la direction générale de la
cohésion sociale a acté le désengagement
des ministères sociaux en inscrivant
période de 2011 une subvention du musée
parc 2 2679 1620 elle passerait à 839
1810 puis à zéro en 2010 sur un budget
de 3 millions cette baisse conduit
immanquablement à la fermeture de
l'établissement dès juin 2011 sa sombre
comme consiste donc à rétabli les
crédits à hauteur de 1679 1620 qui
serait donc porter pour la pole au mans
pour la moitié chacun par le ministère
de l'outre-mer et par le ministère du
travail
et tout en guettant naturellement que
celui-ci se désengage et condamne ainsi
à terme l'existence de cet institut à
vis de la commission
alors j'ai bien entendu notre collègue
bon je voudrais quand même rappeler que
cet institut ne relève pas de la mission
outre-mer
bien évidemment ils forment un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont issus de
l'outre-mer mais c'est pas une raison
pour que cela soit pris en charge par le
budget de l'outre-mer donc nous avons un
avis défavorable nous ne souhaitons pas
que l'on prélève cette somme de 830 9810
euros sur le budget outre mer pour aller
vers le budget formation
monsieur le président en particulier je
voudrais vous indiqué madame la ministre
que nous avions hier soir la discussion
des crédits de la mission enseignement
scolaire et que un amendement
homothétique a été présentée tendant à
extraire des crédits de la mission
enseignement scolaire
la dotation qui vient au profit de cet
institut localisé à dieppe
nous considérons que ça n'est pas
véritablement
des crédits de l'enseignement scolaire
et qu'il devrait sans doute être dans la
sphère de votre ministère donc nous
aimerions connaître votre opinion à ce
sujet et car cet institut n'est pas
complètement reconnu par la mission
enseignement scolaire et peut-être at-il
vocation à trouver sa place dans votre
propre mission ce qui supposerait que
les crédits de l'enseignement scolaire
soit transféré on avait imaginé
hier soir de sortir ces crédits de
l'enseignement scolaire pour que le
gouvernement prenne l'initiative je
parle sous le contrôle de notre collègue
charles revêt car il ya une ambiguïté à
lever à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le président je considère qu
effectivement regard de du rôle que joue
leaf casse en particulier pour la
formation 18 tramain et nous devons
veiller à faire en sorte que ces
établissements puissent continuer à
jouer son rôle ça c'est la première
chose deuxième chose je crois que c'est
plus compliqué qu'on ne le pense parce
que je ne suis pas sûr que les crédits
est vraiment vocation à être affecté au
ministère de l'outre-mer on regarde des
missions qui ont été dévolues à ce
ministère en revanche nous pouvons
imaginer un financement entre plusieurs
ministères actuellement si la réflexion
qui conduite il ya une réunion
interministérielle et vis-à-vis des
sénateurs je voudrais les rassurer
d'abord que par rapport à la rentrée
scolaire tous les moyens sont mobilisés
pour que cette rentrée se passe dans de
bonnes conditions et qu'on puisse aller
jusqu'au bout de cette année scolaire et
que la rentrée 2011 sera assuré en tout
cas j'en ai eu l'engagement au niveau de
mes autres collègues nous avons toute
une année pour déterminer les modèles
fine les modalités de financement de
cette institution
voilà
l'explication de vote monsieur j lo
présidente j'ai entendu une intervention
du président à en tuer bien sûr de la
réponse de la ministre
mais lorsqu'on voit le sens qu'on
voudrait donner justement cet amendement
c'est de dire que c'est de la solidarité
de la continuité territoriale qui fait
effectivement partie effectivement à mon
avis de la mission entre eux maire
d'autant plus ce que nous voulons c'est
la pérennisation de cet institut et nous
demandons justement financements croisés
en aurait souhaité que la réponse de la
ministre me dise effectivement dans un
souci de financement croisé qu'elle
ferait tout pour la pérennisation de cet
institut et si effectivement d'autres
ministères notamment le mystère du
travail de la santé pourrait intervenir
je crois qu'on pourrait y aller a
souvent là cette convention permet de
retirer aujourd'hui mon amendement mais
de voit qu'effectivement c'est quand
même une compétence à mon avis qui
devrait revenir à au ministère du
commerce
je remercie le président ratu pour son
intervention madame la ministre
juste vous apporter la précision
monsieur sénateurs je vous confirme nous
cherchons à pérenniser l'institut dans
son fonctionnement
il ya d'autres moyens financiers qui
peuvent être mobilisés je pense
notamment au fonds social européen
il ya des pistes de travail qui ont été
engagés nous avons combien de dire le
président a depuis l'année pour le faire
en tout cas je peux vous garantir que
l'année la rentrée 2011 sera assurée à
ce niveau là je suis rejet oui merci
même la présidente mam le ministre je
crois que je partage ce que vient de
dire notre collègue
je suis sénateur de seine-maritime et et
c'est institut joue un rôle très
important non seulement pour des
formations l'échelon local mais aussi
pour l'outre-mer et je comprends
l'inquiétude de mes collègues qui se
disent bien c'est bien même me cherche à
trouver une solution très bien si vous
nous disiez même le ministre que si la
solution n'intervient pas dans
l'interministériel vous vous engagez à
ce que le ministère n'avait prochaine
prennent en compte dans son budget le
financement de cet institut alors là
nous serions assurés parce que
chercher c'est bien trouvé c'est
quelquefois plus difficile et vous
comprenez que pour l'institut en
lui-même les personnels qui sont
concernés et pour la mission surtout qui
est rempli par cet institut
il est important qu'on soit sécurisé
pour l'avenir madame la ministre vous
souhaitez compléter votre réponse où je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il est trop tôt
pour dire comment cet institut va être
financé ce d'autant ce d'autant qu'on
peut imaginer aussi des participations
des collectivités locales ultramarines
qui peuvent être aussi sollicités nous
sommes dans le cadre d'une formation
professionnelle donc je crois qu'il est
difficile au travers d'un amendement de
régler la question du financement de cet
institut de formation qui est
indispensable pour nos compatriotes
ultramarins
la seule chose je peux prendre
l'engagement devant l'assemblée que
l'institut continuera de fonctionner
j'ai eu les assurances des autres
ministres concernés nous devons trouver
la meilleure formule qui permette de
garantir cette pérennisation
est ce que cette réponse vous conduit à
maintenir ou à retirer votre amendement
monsieur gillot vous avez la parole
voilà présente le vu les volontés
affichées je crois qu'effectivement nous
pourrons partir sur une garantie dont
pour cette raison je retire mon
amendement merci
nous allons procéder au vote des crédits
de la mission outre-mer figureront à
l'état b je n'ai été saisi d'aucune
demande d'explications de vote avant
l'expiration du délai limite je mets
donc aux voix les crédits de la mission
qui est pour et qui est contre ou
abstentions ils sont adoptés
j'appelle en discussion les articles 77
77 g77 terre 77 kw à terre et 77 15
pièces et les amendements qui sont
rattachés pour leurs examens aux crédits
de la mission outre mer avant l'article
77 nous avons trois amendements en
discussion commune
l'amendement 206 madame payet
merci madame la présidente
alors cet amendement concerne la vente
de tabac dans les dom qui contrairement
à la métropole n'est pas soumise à un
monopole
le parlement a adopté dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2009
l'article 568 bis du code général des
impôts qui organise une procédure de
licences accordées par le conseil
général aux débitants de tabac
ce dispositif présente le double
avantage d'attribuer nouvelles
ressources au département par le biais
d'une redevance est de mettre fin à
l'anarchie complète du marché du tabac
tout en respectant les équilibres
actuels et les commerçants en activité
il s'agit en définitive de moraliser ce
marché est de permettre aux politiques
de prévention de s'appliquer aussi outre
mer depuis deux ans le gouvernement n'a
toujours pas pris le décret
d'application de cet article ce qui crée
une insécurité juridique indéniable pour
les vendeurs puisque la cessation
d'activité des points de vente des
produits de licence est fixé dans
l'article même du code au plus tard le
1er janvier 2011
cet amendement vise en conséquence à
conforter l'environnement juridique du
commerce du tabac dans les dom et à
remédier à l'inertie du gouvernement sur
cette question essentielle de santé
publique
merci madame alors sur cet amendement de
la commission des affaires sociales nous
avons deux sous-amendement le 358
présentée par monsieur virapoullé
vous avez la parole monsieur le sénateur
mais comme la présidente maintenant le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je comprends le souci affiché
par ma collègue anne marie payet sur ce
problème du tabac outre mer qui rejoint
d'ailleurs celui de l'alcoolisme
il y a quelques années j'avais fait
voter au conseil général un doublement
du prix du paquet de cigarettes
la consommation avaient baissé de 25%
puis malheureusement des habitudes
l'emportent sur les sacrifices qu'il
faut fait apprécier un paquet de
cigarettes et la consommation a repris
une courbe ascendante
mon amendement pour but d'améliorer les
conditions d'application de
mon demande ma collègue payet notamment
pour ceux qui ont déjà une licence ceux
qui exploitent cette licence à proximité
des grandes surfaces elles donnent
également gouvernement la possibilité de
prendre un décret pour appliquer le
dispositif prévu par ma collègue de
reporter au 1er juillet la date
d'application prévue au 1er janvier
je pense que cet amendement donne de la
cohérence au texte précédent
il sécurise l'avenir professionnel des
marchands de cigarette parce que ce ne
sont pas des gens qui travaillent au
noir ce sont des gens qui ont des
employés qui ont un chiffre d'affaires
qui ont une famille qui ont un revenu on
peut pas du jour au lendemain
jouer à la loterie avec leur avenir
la cigarette n'a pas été inventé par ces
vendeurs de cigarettes avaient inventé
par notre société est elle est
commercialisée suivant des règles donc
s'adoucit l'application demain
l'amendement madame payet ça donne un
peu de cohérence de la sécurité ça perd
nos gouvernements surtout d'avoir le de
prendre le temps quelques mois pour
mettre en place les procédures légales
il la commission des finances pardon il
ya encore un sous-amendement excusez moi
le 381 monsieur lise merci madame la
présidente
l'amendement de notre collègue payet
dont je peux partager l'objectif de
santé publique pose un problème aux
conseils généraux d'outre-mer
en réalité il a pour conséquence cet
amendement de rendre effectif un
transfert de responsabilités je dirais
même que c'est un transfert de
compétences avec bien entendu un
transfert de change à ses conseils
je veux rappeler que ces conseils
généraux de l'outre-mer elles n'ont pas
été demandeur et
non seulement ils n'ont pas été
demandeur mais ils ont expressément
marqué une opposition à ce transfert
on connaît déjà les difficultés de ces
de ces collectivités suis serait très
malvenue en ce moment un d'opérer un tel
transfert donc mon amendement tend à
supprimer à ce transfert que l'objectif
demeure éventuellement mais que le
président du conseil général ne soit pas
chargée de délivrer les licences dans
les conditions prévues par le texte
avis de la commission des finances sur
l'amendement et les deux sous-amendement
merci madame la présidente dames les
ministres mes chers collègues donc on a
un amendement et deux sous amendement
l'amendement de madame payet vient du
fait que je les décrets d'application
d'une loi votée en juillet 2009 n'ont
pas été pris le premier sous amendement
de monsieur virapoullé temps à assouplir
le calendrier est celui de monsieur
liste en a retiré aux conseils généraux
la délivrance des licences de tabac en
ce qui concerne la commission nous
sollicitons d'abord l'avis du
gouvernement a vu du gouvernement madame
la ministre madame la présidente
effectivement la manne l'amendement
payet vise à mettre en application un
amendement qui avait été approuvé dans
le cadre de la loi de finances 2009 pour
la réglementation des licences de tabac
en outre-mer ce principe était liée au
fait que actuellement les conseils
généraux en outre-mer perçoivent les
droits de consommation et donc il y
avait une logique pour que ce soit les
conseils généraux qui demande puisse
gérer les licences simplement le
gouvernement n'est pas resté inactif sur
ce dossier puisque d'ailleurs madame
payet introduit dans son amendement des
dispositions du décret qui avait été
préparé en ce sens
simplement et le président lise
président du conseil général et sénateur
vient de rappeler les conseils généraux
aujourd'hui pose la question notamment
par rapport à cet objectif de santé
publique qu'on partage bien évidemment
avec madame payet dont je veux saluer
son manque son engagement sa
détermination
mais pour autant il faut regarder
l'impact économique l'impact vis-à-vis
des collectivités locales et je
comprends tout à fait la démarche du
sénateur virapoullé qui souhaite
qu'effectivement nous allions plus loin
dans cette analyse est d'ailleurs moi je
propose
je me suis engagé pour que
fonctionnaires de mon administration
soit mobilisé pendant les trois mois à
venir pour faire je dirais une mise à
plat complète de manière qu'on aborde
l'ensemble des questions et que nous
puissions préparer un décret qui vise à
la fois à répondre à cet objectif de
santé publique que nous partageons tout
ce contenu
je dirais des conséquences du padd du
tabagisme sur la santé mais qui
permettent de trouver un dispositif qui
soit largement partagée par ces
collectivités en particulier les
conseils généraux qui auront à gérer les
licences de tabac donc madame la
ministre ça veut dire avis défavorable
dans ces conditions je propose à madame
payet de retirer son amendement très
bien monsieur le président une question
récurrente et il faudrait qu'on sorte là
encore de l'ambiguïté il y as d'un côté
la référence à des objectifs de santé
publique
c'est si vrai que la loi hôpital santé
patients territoires a pris en compte
cette préoccupation donc on est
irréprochable
au plan législatif mais il y a comme une
disjonction entre la législation et la
pratique et
ce fossé nous fait prendre le risque
d'apparaître soit velléitaire soit
quelque peu hypocrite
donc je pense madame la ministre qu'il
faudrait absolument sortir de cette
situation qui n'est pas acceptable
vous avez annoncé un décret sous trois
mois
c'est bien cela
un décret qui soit de nature à permettre
à la loi d'entrer en application
peut-être que madame payée sous le
bénéfice d'un tel engagement solennel
devant le sénat à l'occasion du vote des
crédits de la mission outre-mer
peut-être que madame payet pourrait
retirer son amendement car je ne m'en
rends pas compte
je salue la la constance et la
détermination et l'engagement de madame
payé monsieur masson vous aviez demandé
la parole pour que compte oui exactement
compte tenu de l'importance de la
fiscalité sur le tabac
je pense qu'il serait opportun que au
niveau de l'ensemble de la france il y
ait une unification du régime général
des tabacs et il y a notamment outre mer
un certain nombre de dispositions qui
sont très pertinentes notamment le fait
que les conseils généraux puissent
percevoir les droits de consommation et
nous sommes en france métropolitaine
nous savons tous que les conseils
généraux manque de financements manquent
de ressources et je pense que c'est un
amendement pourrait être l'occasion pour
nous d'attirer l'attention de madame le
ministre et d'ailleurs du gouvernement
au sens large du terme sur le fait que
peut-être si les départements de
métropole pouvait récupérer également
les droits
le consommation qui sont récupérés par
les départements d'outre-mer et bien on
aurait on compenserait un petit peu les
transferts de charges énormes que
subissent les départements au général et
les séquelles également de la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
alors la deuxième remarque que je vous
réfère pour souligner l'intérêt qu'il y
aurait à uniformiser la réglementation
c'est que on assiste à dire au niveau du
tabac à une multitude des dérogations de
régime différentiel si on regarde par
exemple la corse
il ya eu d il ya eu un vote du parlement
sur l'accord pour proroger le régime de
la corse et le motif avancé pour la
corse était que les buralistes de corse
était et c'est vrai c'était écrit un
c'est pas moi et qu'ils inventent était
menacé par la concurrence des buralistes
d'espagne et d'italie
alors les buralistes d'espagne et
d'italie soit 200 km par bateau prenez
l'exemple des buralistes de moselle il
se trouve à cinq kilomètres des
buralistes du luxembourg ou au
luxembourg le prix d'ailleurs dû tablait
encore plus bas qu'en italie en espagne
et moi je vois pas pourquoi il y aurait
36000 régimes différents les buralistes
de moselle sont aussi respectable que
ceux de corse et je pense que les
départements de métropole mériteraient
également de bénéficier des mêmes
dotations budgétaires des mêmes
transfert que l'outre-mer parce que ce
qui se passe outre mer est très
pertinent et le gouvernement feraient
bien de s'en inspirer un petit peu parce
que les départements de métropole comme
d'ailleurs les départements d'outre-mer
rencontrent des difficultés budgétaires
considérables et il serait temps que le
débat que le gouvernement fasse quelque
chose pour aider les départements
madame la présidente dénis et madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
moi je voudrais bien entendu madame
payet qui s'exprime au nom de notre
commission des affaires sociales j'ai
bien entendu monsieur virapoullé et
monsieur lisent
et globalement je suis d'accord avec les
3 ce qui me choque profondément dans
cette situation et ça n'est pas la
première fois
c'est que il faut que l'une d'entre nous
madame payet dépose un amendement au nom
de la commission
pour qu'on se rende compte que quelque
chose qui a été décidé
il y a deux ans n'a pas pu être mises en
oeuvre et que maintenant madame la
ministre s'engage à le faire rapidement
dans les trois mois qui viennent ça
n'est pas la première fois
ça n'est sans doute pas la dernière ça a
quelque chose d' extrêmement choquant et
je crois que ce c'est quelque chose qui
arrive très souvent en ce qui concerne
nos départements et nos territoires
d'outre-mer et c'est aussi choquant que
quand ça ce propos ça se passe pour la
métropole mais le nombre de lois et vous
le savez madame madame la présidente
madame la ministre
le nombre de lois qui ne sont pas mises
en oeuvre au bout de plusieurs années
parce qu'on n'a pas pris les décrets
d'application est extrêmement choquant
et je me demande pourquoi on nous fait
voter des lois dont on sait pertinemment
qu'on appliquera pas content de m'être
ne mettra pas les décrets d'application
madame le rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales oui madame la
présidente je voudrais vous dire que je
ne comprends pas l'hostilité de la
ministre alors nous nous sommes
entretenus longuement à ce sujet
vendredi
et vous dites que les présidents de
conseils généraux auront une trop grande
marge de manoeuvre qui pourront accorder
des licences à 1 euro selon un choix qui
sera entachée de favoritisme mais je
vous demande de faire un peu confiance
aux présidents des collectivités
ce sont des gens responsables qui seront
faire preuve de sagesse et de
discernement et appliquer cette mesure
avec souplesse et rien n'empêche le
ministre de l'air adressé une circulaire
ou un simple courrier pour leur préciser
de fixer un prix intermédiaire au départ
pour que la réforme ne soit pas brutal
et prévoir un réajustement annuel pour
atteindre le niveau métropole dans dix
ans par exemple mon amendement a été
adopté en décembre 2008
l'application était prévue au 1er
janvier 2011 j'ai laissé deux ans au
gouvernement pour engager ce disque
avec les conseillers généraux et pour
ensuite publié le décret des projets de
décrets ont été préparé par bercy
vous avez jugé que la rédaction n'était
pas parfaite sans proposer toutefois de
modification il y avait trop
d'imprécisions et je suis sûr que s'il y
avait plus de précision on aurait pu me
reprocher de ne pas laisser suffisamment
de libre de liberté de manoeuvre aux
conseils généraux le délai arrive à
expiration et je pense que le
gouvernement doit faire preuve de
courage pour que l'application soit
effective au 1er janvier le premier
ministre dans son discours de politique
générale m'a conforté dans ma position
je me suis vraiment senti en phase avec
lui en l'écoutant avec toute l'attention
qu'il mérite
la pause est la marque d un déficit at
il dit et l'indécision serait une
revanche de la peur la peur du
changement qui nous a longtemps conduit
à célébrer la théorie du ni-ni est
allouée celle du temps laissé autant
alors ayons le courage madame la
ministre mes chers collègues de mener
cette réforme à son terme en ce qui
concerne sous-amendement de jean paul
virapoullé ce sous-amendement remet
complètement en cause d'un amendement de
la commission des affaires sociales
premièrement il décale la date d'entrée
en vigueur au 1er juillet 2011
deuxièmement elle autorise une
dérogation pour certains commerçants
surtout il renvoie à nouveau
l'application du mécanisme des licences
à un décret inutile de vous dire mes
chers collègues que je ne vois pas
pourquoi le gouvernement le prendre et
ait duré le premier dur durant le
premier semestre 2011 alors qu'ils
refusent de le faire depuis plusieurs
mois et il refuse le fait en remettant
en cause non pas mon amendement
d'aujourd'hui mais ce que nous avons
votée il ya deux ans en outre il ne
propose même pas d'amendement en
conséquence c'est vraiment illogique
cents à vouloir bafoué les décisions du
parlement
au final je ne peux donc être
défavorable aux sous amendement présenté
par jean paul virapoullé concernant
l'amendement de claude lise
alors je comprends tout à fait les
arguments des présidents de conseils
généraux qui sont présents
ce qui est important c'est que le
mécanisme des licences soit effectif
je suis donc favorable à ce sous
amendement je vais demander l'avis de la
commission des finances
maintenant que nous avons entendu l'avis
du gouvernement l'avis de la commission
des finances commission des finances est
bien embarrassé puisque le président de
la commission l'a dit tout à l'heure sur
le plan législatif on a fait notre
travail mais il semble qu'au niveau de
l'exécutif il y ait un retard dans
l'application
alors madame payet dit je veux
l'application d'un décret au 1er janvier
2011 alors que le décret n'est pas prêt
donc ça semble matériellement difficile
cela dit si on si on suit les
propositions de madame la ministre ne
peut être à nos yeux que la dernière
fois que vous prenez un tel engagement
de produire enfin ce décret dans les six
mois si dans un an on revient ici vous
nous dites j'ai renommée un
fonctionnaire de mon administration pour
faire le point et le constat ça va pas
marcher
matériellement vous pouvez pas publier
le décret maintenant mais engagez-vous
vraiment formellement à dire dans les
six mois effectivement il y aura il y
aura ce décret d'application dans ces
conditions là nous souhaiterions que
madame payet retire son amendement
madame paillé madame la présidente le
décret ne vais pas changer
l'attribution aux conseils généraux et
par contre je ne retiens pas mon
amendement
monsieur lise je pense que l'amendement
que j'ai présentées mais quand même pas
d'un certain nombre de précisions
il fixe l'entrée en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2011 il prévoit qu'une licence
ne vaudra que pour un point de vente
il fixe le nombre de licences par
département et je large rappelle qu'ont
appris les conclusions d'un rapport
effectué par bercy un point de vente
pour 750 habitants en ce moment en outre
mer c'est un point de vente pour 320
habitants on a fait une mesure
intermédiaire en métropole c'est un
point de vente pour 3500 habitants
donc ce que je propose n'est pas brutal
je pense que c'est tout à fait
acceptable en plus ils organisent une
période transitoire de six mois pour les
détaillants qui n'obtiendrait pas de
licence et qui doivent naturellement
pouvoir revendre leurs stocks et il
supprime en conséquence le renvoie à un
décret qui devient inutile porter vous
pourriez peut-être saisir la suggestion
de la commission des finances qui serait
de donner une date un peu plus éloigné
si j'ai bien compris
l'argument et cela permettrait peut-être
au gouvernement de vous donner un avis
favorable
si vous madame la ministre a évoqué une
mission de 3 mois
voilà non vous pouvez toujours rectifier
votre amendement en madame le rapporteur
à l'amendement de la commission
alors si la rectification peut se faire
par exemple pour le 1er avril vers
condition que ça ne renvoie pas encore à
un décret
madame lamia une mission puis-je mission
a déjà été réalisé par bercy
une nouvelle mission la sénatrice
moi j'ai envie de vous dire oui à une
mission effectivement nous pourrions
nous contenter de ce décret je considère
dans la responsabilité qu'il aime qui
est la mienne de dire qu'il faut
compléter cette mission pourquoi d'abord
il ya que sur l'objectif de santé
publique qui est noble et que nous
partagions tous aujourd'hui en métropole
il est de un débit de tabac pour 3000
habitants nous fixons à 1 pour 550 pour
la guadeloupe 1 pour mille pour la
martinique est un sport 750 pour la
réunion
pourquoi l'objectif de santé publique ne
pourrais pas être le même sur le
territoire métropolitain ou en outre-mer
nous pourrions envisager dans le cadre
de ce décret une mesure progressive pour
tenir compte notamment de la situation
économique et qu'au bout du compte nous
ayons les mêmes objectifs de santé
publique que nous soyons en métropole où
que nous soyons en outre-mer la santé un
sujet d'intérêt général et à ce titre là
cette question n'a pas été envisagé
donc rien que sur ce point là je pense
que ça nécessite que nous puissions
regarder les choses de plus près et par
ailleurs je vous indique que lorsque le
décret celui qui a été préparé a été
soumis aux collectivités pas de manière
officielle
mais dans une première approche nous
avons eu à juste titre des observations
qui nous paraissent pertinentes et vous
le savez mieux que moi la présidente du
conseil régional de la réunion générale
de la réunion a saisi officiellement le
gouvernement sur cette question donc et
le président lise le conseil général de
la martinique à la même position ainsi
que le conte le président du conseil
général de la guadeloupe ici présents à
la même position et le président du
conseil général de la guyane
donc je crois qu'il est de bonne mesure
de donner au gouvernement et je prends
l'engagement ici devant la
représentation nationale 2 le
faire parce qu'il faut qu'on travaille
en profondeur et il faut qu'on arrive à
mettre en place un décret qui au bout du
compte ce sera vraiment applicable dans
l'intérêt de l'objectif qu'on partage
tous monsieur lille oui madame la
présidente je voulais réagir tout à
l'heure c'était un point d'ordre fait
parce que j'ai été très choqué dans les
propos qui ont été rapportés dans tant
que l'épisode conseils généraux dans
cette affaire seraient tentés 1,2 de se
livrer à je ne sais quel favoritisme ce
n'est pas ça le problème
le problème c'est qu'il s'agit là d'un
transfert de compétences et de change
contre l'avis des conseils généraux dans
une situation difficile
je veux dire profitant de l'occasion à
certains de mes collègues de l'hexagone
que nous ne percevons pas la taxe sur
les tabacs mais une taxe additionnelle
et que ceci a été fait j'étais
d'ailleurs à l'origine de cela dans la
loi d'orientation pour l'outre-mer
parce que nous avons une insuffisance de
ressources et qui il ne faudrait pas non
plus qu'on se trompe sur les raisons
pour lesquelles nous avons sept
c'est peut-être ce le bénéfice de cette
taxe additionnelle alors sinon c'est
pratiquement toutes les ressources qu'il
va falloir revoir je signale que
aujourd'hui le conseil général de la
martinique se trouve avec une dette de
l'état de 71 millions d'euros
la guadeloupe c'est plus de 4 93
millions la réunion je crois que ça doit
dépasser les 200 millions d'euros
etc etc donc je pense que souvent madame
la présidente par la ministre les
raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes dans
ces difficultés viennent aussi du fait
que l'on vote de manière précipitée et
de manière un petit peu on peut dire bon
petit peu trop trop partisane certaines
dispositions sans que l'on ait poussé la
réflexion jusqu'au bout c'est ce qui
s'est passé là dessus sommes tous
d'accord sur l'objectif
mais
il ya eu un vote bien sûr qui a été un
vote partisan sans qu'on soit allé au
bout de la réflexion et on s'est rendu
compte après il y avait une difficulté
dans la mise en oeuvre
donc encore une fois nous sommes
d'accord sur l'objectif
mais je pense que peut-être qu'il faut
que nous nous donnions le temps de
trouver une solution juste équitable et
efficace que gillot maintenant la
présence je voudrais donner de chiffre
et bien sûr nous sommes tout à fait dans
la philosophie
nous leur disons de l'amendement payet
mais à deux chiffres à prendre en compte
il ya d'abord les charges qui vont
combes et au conseil général
la simulation qu'on a pu faire ensemble
ces dix personnes qu'on devrait là
encore embauché pour mener à terme ce
d'ici là car certains pensent parce que
nous avons quelques heureuses de vent
sur la taxe additionnelle qu'on a déjà
de l'argent non deuxième chose c'est le
nombre de licences attribuées
aujourd'hui nous partons sur 550
nous avons téléphoné au siège des
douanes pour la guadeloupe ce entre 1200
et 2000 licence aujourd'hui qui existent
ou la martinique c'est pareil et sur la
réunion c'est 1500 à 2000 nous sommes
tout à fait d'accord mais nous pensions
qu effectivement profitons de de cette
possibilité si voulez je dirais même de
cette sagesse pour qu'on puisse mieux
mettre misant mettre en en place
l'amendement de de madame payet parce
qu'il faut tenir compte du nombre de
licences il a fait de débit aux outils
existants pour qu'on puisse déterminer
les licences monsieur le président
arthuis
je pense que nos collègues ultramarins
j'entendais notre collègue lise il ya un
instant doivent considérer aussi qu' il
ya sans doute des spécificités
ultramarines
mais le principe qui avait été retenu
c'est celui d'une responsabilité
transféré au conseil général la
contrepartie étant la perception d'une
redevance une redevance par lé conseil
général à la délivrance de ces licences
et s'accompagnait d'une ressource pour
les conseils généraux
c'est bien cela qui était prévu dans le
dispositif donc je m'étonne que sur ce
point vous soyez en désaccord c'est
qu'il ya manifestement une une
incompréhension dans le contenu de cette
législation
donc que le ministre consulte les
conseils généraux je trouve c'est une
bonne manière
je tiens à vous dire que en en france
métropolitaine s'est pas toujours le cas
sur les dispositions que les conseils
généraux doivent appliquer donc cette
bonne manière ne doit pas avoir pour
conséquence l'ajournement du passage à
l'acte car cette disjonction entre la
loi votée et la mise en oeuvre fragilise
considérablement la démocratie et la
république
car c'est l'affichage permanent de
l'impuissance politique et mes chers
collègues je vous mets en garde contre
de telles pratiques qui participent à
une sorte de désenchantement général
donc sortons de ses ambiguïtés
pour le reste nous devons tous être bien
conscients que notre sac à bonne
nouvelle est épuisé et que compte tenu
de la situation de nos finances
publiques nous sommes dans l'obligation
d'être pédagogue et de mettre nos
concitoyens qu'ils soient ultra marins
ou métropolitains en face de leurs
responsabilités et des obligations de la
république voilà donc madame la ministre
il faut que nous sortions de cette
ambiguïté il ya vraiment urgence
si j'avais une constitution je vous
demanderai de jurer sur la constitution
que sous trois mois que sous trois mois
vous aurez pris ce décret et pour que
cette loi devienne effective
monsieur mais je m'étais permis de
demander la parole parce qu'on voit bien
qu'on est quand même dans une situation
un peu bloqué un peu difficile où il ya
des positions qui sont très variées bon
je comprends mais mme dini tout à
l'heure la présidente qui effectivement
a fait part de ce qu'on ressent tous
mais je pense qu'on peut même aller au
delà de la non parution de décrets c'est
qu'à chaque fois qu'un ministre nous dit
votre amendement est extraordinaire
retirer le et je remettrai dans le
prochain texte et qui en vient jamais
c'est à peu près du même du même tonneau
si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi l'objet
déception n'en a régulièrement bon ça
c'est classique
ce que ce que je souhaiterais quand même
c'est que bon en écoutant ce qui est dit
et madame le ministre
de toute façon elle ne peut pas le
sortir le décret dans les jours qui
viennent et dans les semaines qui
viennent et dans l'est dans les trois
mois elle a besoin de trois mois pour le
préparer et trois mois techniquement
pour le sortir donc on en arrive à
l'amendement de monsieur virapoullé qui
effectivement est que sur lequel madame
payet est pas d'accord monsieur
virapoullé nous dit donnons six mois
officiellement au travers d'un vote que
nous allons prendre et sur lequel madame
le ministre doit s'engager pour nous
sortir le document par ailleurs on voit
bien que ce texte a été voté alors j'ai
pu dans quelles conditions à l'époque et
que les présidents de conseils généraux
qui sont ici sont tous dans une
situation délicate parce qu'ils ont du
mal à voir comment ils vont appliquer
dans les conditions d'aujourd'hui un
décret qui n'est pas encore préparés
d'ailleurs dans l'eure à l'intérieur de
leur département dont moi il me semble
et ce n'est pas aller à l'encontre de la
volonté mêlant paillettes sa volonté
c'est qu'on puisse appliquer le texte le
plus rapidement possible or le plus
rapidement possible ça peut pas être en
janvier et en février en mars au 1er
avril
donc ça c'est une certitude donc il faut
trouver les voies les moyens aujourd'hui
de le faire appliquer dans les
meilleures conditions qui soient
madame le ministre a priori nous a quand
même dit à deux reprises qu'elle prenait
l'engagement que ça serait fait au 30
juin ou au 1er juillet c'est à dire dans
les six mois ce qui correspond à
l'amendement de monsieur virapoullé
bon alors où on vote un amendement de
monsieur virapoullé et on répond au
souhait du ministre on répond très
partiellement aux souhaits de madame
payet bien évidemment parce que elle
veut que ça soit immédiat mais s'il
ministre nous dit que ça peut pas être
immédiat comment fait on tourne autour
on tourne autour du sujet et on peut
tourner pendant on va demander à
monsieur le président arthuis de
reporter encore d'autres discussions qui
doit y avoir sur d'autres budgets a donc
un jour parce que on peut rester 15
jours sur un sujet comme ça voilà donc
pour la séance de cet après midi
consacrée au projet de loi de finances
pour 2011 tout de suite preuve par trois
michel grossiord reçoit cécile duflot la
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts
et bien sûr vous pouvez toujours
retrouver la séance en vod sur notre
site publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne
comment se cogner la folie comment
traiter